foreign
Minneapolis Minnesota Thomas is there
Thomas how can we help
Ken George how are you guys well we're
having a blast how are you holding up
out there
good man good so I got an interesting
one for you guys
um so I about almost a year ago now I
bought a 22 Toyota Tundra and I paid way
too much for it how much so I'm trying
to well about 83. it's a it's a I know
it gets worse is the limited it's a
limited so it was about I didn't know
too much of the time I just liked the
truck and I wanted to get it and I
rolled over negative equity from two
previous vehicles
um so it was the sticker on it was 57.
and I didn't know that because I didn't
I know I know I know
um and so the
so I'm I owe 73 left on it now
five of that is in warranty so it's
about 68 is what I
and then the best offer I've got is from
a local dealership there they said
they'd give me 53 for it well to make it
worse I put a lot of miles on it I got
about 36 000 and Counting
but they'll still give you the 53 for it
with the current mileage
isn't that incredible I know that's
which leads the foods is kind of a lead
up to where I'm going because Kelly Blue
Book was somewhere between like 46 and
48 I told the whole story I think they
took video on me I don't know but I
think they're helping me out
so I don't have enough cash to cover the
negative equity and I can't I've tried
to get a personal loan and they're
saying they don't want to do it because
we did just buy a house too who's there
um uh a couple of the personal owned
people online maybe credit cards I think
they think my uh debt to income might be
pretty fast I'm guessing what other debt
do you have
so we just bought a house in January
and I have about 12 900 in credit cards
and then I have about 45 in student
loans
it's a private loan so I don't think the
credit bureaus know about it so I don't
know if that would affect getting a
personal loan or not
um and then my wife has about 15 in
student loans
and I think that about sums it up and
maybe with some little medical bills
here and there
and what's your household income
it says probably like 180 last year it
should be more this year okay that is
good news
so you need to save up fifteen thousand
dollars to cover the difference and then
we still need a different vehicle for
you correct you have two cars right now
right right no no we have we have one
car and I drive now that we moved up to
Minneapolis I drive about 50 to 60 000
miles a year for work which is why I'm
trying to get out of this ASAP while I
have the deal from that dealership at
that offer and then I have about 7 000
cash I should be getting you know a
pretty good sized paycheck coming up
here next but I still need a car and so
the question is my dad is willing to
co-sign on like one of those zero
percent for 20 21 month credit cards
that pay off the difference
and then I would just pay that down as
soon as possible so the question is
should I do that or should I you're
giving me heartburn right now just
thinking about the situation Thomas
goodness we need to get Ken some Tums
yeah oh yeah yeah I've already eaten two
Tums off the mic as soon as you told me
the price can he not get a local bank to
give him the difference have you tried
going to a credit union not one of these
online situations I I called it I called
a local credit union they said that the
most that they would do for something
like this is probably five thousand
um
okay so let's say you could get 5K
you're still down 10K
how quickly making 180 plus it's 15.
it's 15 because I get five back but
after I pay it first does that make
sense so there's a five thousand dollar
warranty on the truck that gets refunded
once I either cancel it but I don't want
to cancel until I pay okay so let's say
you use this month you use six from your
bank that you have right now and we'll
use the new five that you get refunded
towards a vehicle
so if I use the six in the bank
plus you get five from the you said the
credit union will give you five that
gives you eleven now we're just down
four grand
so then we're gonna hustle to get these
next paychecks you have another five
well it's 20 000 that I have to write a
check for and then they're gonna mail me
a check for 5 000 back in a month okay
for the warranty takes a month to get it
back to you if I cancel right now then
it just kind of makes it tougher I think
because I still have to write the whole
20. so the number the magic number we
need is nine thousand between the loan
from the credit union and the six you
have in the bank let's keep a thousand
in there for emergencies that puts you
at a deficit of nine thousand how
quickly can you stack up nine thousand
dollars
all right that's pretty quick I might
get it on the next check I mean you have
to because you got to take this deal I'm
gonna beg that dealer to say hey I'm
gonna get this money to you but I need a
month to get out from under this thing
can you and have them sign some things
given your deadline for it to where he
knows you're good for it yeah because
here's my question forgive my forgive
but sometimes the most ignorant question
is the right question
so I'm gonna volunteer thank you George
here's what I'm wondering on his behalf
he's going to sell the truck to a
different dealer than he bought it from
is that correct
correct the one I bought it from said
I'd come out smelling like a rose if
they gave me that for it right but my
point is is that if you go to this
dealer today and and he buys it from me
for 53. you owe 15. that's still that
you owe that to the other dealer so
they're not asking for that right away
they're spoiled up Toyota financial yeah
but I mean do you have to pay that off
immediately because you still owe it
right
right so oh well I don't know this will
give me 53 if I don't give them the
title yeah you're gonna have to have a
clean title to do that I can't be alone
there's there's where my ignorance comes
in I knew it was in there somewhere yeah
but I just asked no no credit card no
zero percent no co-signing like you're
this is the same deal when you rolled in
two negative equities like we're just
making the problem worse
right but then if I but I also have to
drive I need a vehicle also so I was
thinking if I use my cash to buy like a
5 000 car I have to drive for work like
I drive people's houses all day and
there's no company vehicle I could rent
a car no yeah you might need to rent a
car you can look into turo as well yeah
and and you know you're paying 40 bucks
a day to rent something that's what I
would do and some of them you're gonna
have to look into unlimited mileage with
those otherwise you're going to get
dinged pretty hard driving over the
limits uh so you're gonna have to get
creative for a little while man but dude
you make 200 Grand we don't have to play
these games anymore
and so I'm saving up nine thousand
dollars as quickly as I can I'm working
overtime I'm delivering pizzas whatever
you got to do some stuff in the next 30
days
yeah what do you got in the house you
got any expensive toys
uh no you got an exercise bike you got
literally anything you can sell today on
Facebook golf clubs are they nice golf
clubs oh they're great man they're the
best and they're gone today
oh man you're doing it no come on you're
killing January in Minnesota right where
are you golfing you guys can't play golf
for six more months and that's okay
we're cutting up the cards we're saying
no more to negative equity we're done
with this Thomas we're doing whatever it
takes to get out from under this thing
we believe in you buddy you know what to
do